where we left off in the last video we
saw Julius Caesar had conquered Gaul as
proconsul and near the end of his term
as proconsul the senators in Rome were
afraid of him he was this popular
populist
charismatic figure he had just had these
significant military victories in Gaul
and they said all right Caesar why don't
you just leave your position leave your
army and return to Rome
well Caesar sitting over here saying
well that doesn't really make a lot of
sense if I were just returned to Rome
they already are threatened by me who
knows what they're going to do to me
so he decides to cross the Rubicon and
enter Rome and so the Roman senators
they say okay let's get Pompey the
famous general who used to be part of
Caesars triumphs or it but had switched
sides to engage with Caesar but Pompey
says you know what I'm not so sure if
Caesar is beatable right now he wasn't
aware that Caesar only had one Legion
maybe there was a trick up Julius Caesar
sleeves so Pompey takes his forces and
retreats across the Adriatic to regroup
with the intent of coming back and
retaking Rome and so you can imagine a
lot of the Senators especially the
powerful senators who in opposition to
Julius Caesar go along with Pompey so
Julius Caesar even though he's now in
control of Rome he knows that this isn't
the end of it that a civil war has
become that it's only a matter of time
before Pompey's forces and these
senators return and retake Rome so he
decides to take the fight to them he
puts his second-in-command Marcus
Antonius
often known as Mark Antony who was one
of his generals in the Gallic Wars he
puts him in charge of he puts him in
charge in Italy and then Julius Caesar
leads his several of his legions off
across the Adriatic and it's a pretty
interesting story in its own right they
cross during the winter which was a bit
of a surprise attack because no one
would have expected them to cross the
winter in the Adriatic and to break the
blockade of Pompey because Pompey
controlled the Navy but he's able to
engage Pompey several times and then
finally in 48b
seee he is able to decisively beat
Pompey at fought at the bottle of
Pharsalus which is right over here in
central Greece
so the his enemies his opponents Julius
Caesar's enemies are now defeated and
Pompey is in retreat he tries to escape
to Alexandria and this is where the the
story gets even more interesting so just
as a little bit of background in 51 BCE
so right about there on that timeline
and right about here on this timeline
Ptolemy the 12th who was the Pharaoh of
Egypt dies Ptolemy Ptolemy the 12th
passes away
and this was a little bit of background
it was called Ptolemaic Egypt and even
this guy was called Ptolemy because you
might remember that Alexander the Great
when he conquered Persia in the 330s BCE
he also conquered Egypt and then once
Alexander the Great passed once he died
one of his generals Ptolemy Ptolemy the
first established the Ptolemaic Empire
over Egypt established Ptolemaic Egypt
and so this is Ptolemaic Egypt right
over here which was significantly less
powerful than the Roman Empire and
historical accounts that they
essentially bribed their way to maintain
their independence up to this point but
Ptolemy the 12th when he dies in 51 BCE
dies in 51 b.c.e
in his will he wants two of his children
to cowrote rule Ptolemaic Egypt and they
were young one of them Ptolemy
creatively named Ptolemy xiii was 10
years old and his daughter the other one
that he wanted to Clicquot rule
Cleopatra was 18 years old and this is a
picture of Cleopatra and this is now the
Cleopatra when in popular culture the
movie Cleopatra when people talk about
Cleopatra this is the Cleopatra they're
talking about but you can imagine this
KO rule thing doesn't really work out
that well and civil war has broken out
in Ptolemaic Egypt with the supporters
of Ptolemy the thirteen
you can imagine this is only a ten year
old young young kid it's really the
adults that are probably running the
show but the supporters of ptolemy
ptolemy xiii are the ones that seem to
have the upper hand at the time that
Pompey is running away to Alexandria
which is the seat of power city
established by Alexander the Great and
the seat of power in Ptolemaic Egypt now
the supporters of ptolemy xiii they say
okay we don't want to mess around with
julius caesar who seems to be quite
powerful with his legions so why don't
we do him a favor
when Pompey comes why don't we kill him
and so in 49 B or 48 BCE this is after
remember Pharsalus Pharsalus was in for
August of 48 BCE you have Pompey leaving
and in 48 BCE he is killed so Pompey is
now killed in 48 BCE by the supporters
of ptolemy xiii thinking that this is
going to carry carry favor with them
with Julius Caesar
well Julius Caesar really does not like
this he wanted to he likes to establish
his reputation as a magnanimous ruler
someone who likes to forgive his enemies
someone who wants to unify the people of
Rome and so he's in pursuit of Pompey
when he gets to Alexandrian realizes
that he was killed by ptolemy xiii
supporters he decides to take the other
side and join forces with Cleopatra and
not only is he able to support her in a
political military sense he helps her
defeat her enemies and become and come
on to the throne become the Pharaoh of
Ptolemaic Egypt he also has a fate and
affair with Cleopatra and at the time
this is now 48 BC 48 BCE where you have
so let's see this is 50 49 48 BCE which
is roughly 40 late 48th and early 47 BCE
where when Julius Caesar was actually in
Alexandria they actually have an affair
and this is a julius caesar who was in
his early 50s and this is a Cleopatra
who is in her early 20s and through that
affair
they have by most accounts a child
cesarean later on but this affair puts
or I guess this support for Cleopatra
puts Cleopatra on the throne and even
though Zhu Caesar does not take control
of Ptolemaic Egypt it makes Ptolemaic
Egypt something of a client state
something of a client state of the Roman
Empire and then Julius Caesar returns
back to Rome he does mend several other
things engaging in the east here but
eventually he gets back to Rome and over
several periods he gets himself declared
dictator and dictator today has a term
of someone who kind of takes power maybe
unlawfully someone who just runs the
show under Roman law under the Roman
Republic there was actually a position
called dictator that could be appointed
for these six-month terms especially
when there was in times of emergency
that they could do whatever they needed
to do but now he got appointed dictator
multiple terms and for more than six
months and in 46 he gets elected
dictator for 10 years so now 46 BCE is
see this is 45:46 BCE he gets elected
dictator for a term of 10 years and then
in 44 BCE he gets he declared he gets
declared dictator for life now this
whole time even though he tried to be
someone somewhat conciliatory against
his enemies his enemies were kind of
brooding and saying what can we do to
get back at this and so on March 15th 44
BCE and this is one of the most famous
dates in history his opponents in the
Senate led by Marcus Junius Brutus
literally attack Julius Caesar in Rome
and this is an artist's depiction of
that attack and they kill him you might
have heard of the Ides of March Ides of
March that is the date March 15th and
it's referring when people say it today
they're referring to that event that
happened that happened on March 15 44
BCE where the dictator of Rome and he
was really Emperor even though he wasn't
Claire temper yet he had absolute power
over Rome Julius Caesar was killed by
his enemies and that those enemies were
led by Marcus Junius Brutus
and as you can imagine this then puts
Rome into another phase I guess you
could say of the civil war or you could
say into another civil war now before we
leave Julius Caesar it is worth saying
some of the things he did he did try to
do some of these populist reforms
he's also well known for establishing
the Julian calendar Julian calendar the
Roman calendar before the Julian
calendar was got pretty off on an annual
basis but the Julian calendar got a lot
closer to our current Gregorian calendar
that we use today so the days didn't
shift as much as earth orbited around
the Sun so I'll leave you there and in
the next few videos we'll talk about
what happened after Julius Caesar the
Civil War I really could say the civil
wars that broke out and how they really
culminated with Rome officially going
from being a republic to an empire